c'è una storia seria voci noi siamo già
costo per super entusiasmate studio
ricordate il millepiedi di aghi luoghi
cioè questa volta c'è il serpente è
infatti uno di noi si trasforma in un
serpente dobbiamo scappare ben iniziamo
subito voglio solo se si piace anche di
ricordati i preti buon corno qualcosa da
terra devono lasciare
ok eccoci qua dove siamo siamo tv
offerta terraneo
ospita abbinato al mio outfit
che aveva operato per una passeggiata è
certo siamo in tanti che carini che
siamo chi ti
aspetta cosa qua sono
a
vado a controllare
[Musica]
ah ok è stato preso dal serpente
credo che avere diventato lui il
serpente debutto minuti per scappare ok
cosa dobbiamo fare prendiamo le monete e
dove sono le monete non li vedo questa
musica mi sto facendo mountain biker
aprile primo no no no solo presso le
monete però mi ha dato un'ottima idea
una chiave c'è una chiave qua aspetta
aspetta che controlla il frigo prenderla
ok ho preso una chiave arancione apre la
porta a rho questo giallo per
simulazione
qua ci sono delle altre monete presto
prima che arrivi serpente
qualcosa così questa dinamica credo che
il serpente stia arrivando forse arrivi
fra poco ancora non si è visto
che cos'era quel rumore ma si vuole la
richiesta non la chiara rosa nel
martarello quindi non equa
forse una cosa ti seguo aiuto ha paura
ci sono dei suoni strani inquietanti
direi solo gli altri giocatori sono
stati ci sono già ma se fosse l'inizio
battuti esser peppers e cosa questa
terapia proprio questa porta brava brava
troppo bravo verte la guardano bene
credo che presa ho preso la chiave blu
cerchiamo la porta blu da aprire tornati
dov'eravamo
vero vitale
eccolo di brutto
dove sei sono solo nella schermata
principale iniziale non so se mi sono
posto la pole in serpente si no
e poi tu avevi la chiave blue sky
proprio pensili praticamente la ha detto
sì ma dove domandare che cosa devo
aprire è prova proprio guardarti intorno
un bomba che ansia la selezione di sola
come non lo so
mi sembra non può dipendere li
fai scappare da lì forse no tutto chiuso
perché sono dato la mi sa che gli altri
se l'è pappa di tutti
allora vedi si trovi di qua di qua delle
scale
ok il servizio della strada che abbia
già un altro chiave di
è appreso ha vinto serpente ok ecco
cinema ricominciamo capiterà serpente
questa volta sia sarebbe essere sempre
al kamber
chi sarà il serpente questa volta
vediamo chi prendere secondo me vitale
non solo per piantare testori sì o no io
sono per
vedere subito
non vede l'ora di andare a maggiora vita
allora ferma i giocatori che fuggono
posizionare trappole che fortunatamente
non puoi saltare ma la
dai buchi nel muro per raggiungere altre
parole della mappa uno sviluppo da
arriva da
dove devo andare
dove devo andare adesso forse fatto
anita serpente sta arrivando a mangiarti
vita ne ho io scatto il vaso
è stata data a mario mura possa dare
questi buchi qua per strisciare
non hai scampo vitale
allora mettiamo qualche trappola
ecco questa è una trappola
come le trappole che vuol dire le
trappole è la scoprirai tra il bando di
mangiar ha
fatto per finito evitare nascosto bene
non trova neanche nessun altro giocatore
vediamo se c'è qualcuno al piano di
sopra gente
è il resto ad aprire la porta buffa
una porta blu la porta verde
ti prego
vai xkè faccio questi versi la
cavalletta vabbè comunque ho preso un
giocatore
mimetica irritare ci sono anche altri
giocatori e reggae per forza di
riprendere bene ma io non li ho visto
nessun altro e poi più divertente no è
più divertente trovare inventore vitali
geneticamente 13 sotto di farsi mangiare
[Musica]
lunga più che un serpente sembrò tipo
una ruba
causerebbero un hardware domano tutta
strada allora dove saranno gli altri
giocatori
own site uno dietro di sé grazie per
l'invito
a
non puoi scappare a danilo carpente
lasciamo andare ei dovete fare
si no vediamo chi sarà serpente questa
volta vitale o qualcun altro
mi chiamo
mamma mia devo scappare novità di
serpente che sarà spietatissimo ciao
all'inter sono piccolo che adora prima
mio idolo ce che voi nostri fan
mi raccomando non mangiare i nostri fan
e non posso garantire su questo
sito
perché c'è i capelli così grandi
aiuto ho messo la trappola ti posso bit
andare a prendere la chiave non mi
ricordo vera era sul tavolo sul quale
tavolo no niente
c'è qui che c'è qualcuno
non ci crede e mangiato un nostro fan lo
sto per mangiare no è un altro nostro
fan
e adesso siamo fuori certo che questa
casa però non è con i buchi per i
serpenti tra le stanze in claudiana la
casa ha detto
qui c'è la vita
[Musica]
vediamo se messo una trappola ma sarà la
chiave sul tavolo ma non c'è più
noi diamo scappa scappa da da mangiare
prima gli altri
che figo esplorando la stazza le stanze
come come serpente
possa scendere giù no non posso scendere
giù forse ora mi ricorrerà qua forse la
chiave voi vi ricordate dove cavolo era
chiave gialla sì io lo so dove la chiave
giusta e sul e sul tavolino là fuori e
si brava proprio dove stai andando
adesso non c'è quindi la presa destra
guardati indietro ha
detto
ti prendo
la mia che bello la ricerca alla ricerca
ma proviamo subito
mancheranno sbagliare perché sono farmi
dietro di te
aiuto sbrigati
blu e vuole chiave blu perché non c'è
eccolo
preso
mi sono messo lì apposta di
proposito prossima partita vediamo se
adesso invece troveremo tutti e due
giocatori senza essere serpenti ok il
nostro fan adesso è un problema vediamo
se prendo nostro fanno magari non ci
mangiano
troppo curiosa perché aprirlo adesso
proprio modello arriviamoci ora che
sappiamo dove sono nati
mi raccomando di gioco di squadra sì sì
mi ricordo che qui c'era la chiave
gialla giusto no l'attività l'era su un
tavolino che non mi ricordo dovere che
cosa ha prima che facciano i porri da
noi ma che le griglie getta sono qua
fuori o due chiavi le visioni e vero c'e
la pioggia l'acqua fuori una memoria
terribile ecco c'è una chiave rosa prove
sicure chiave rosa e fuori scusate
cambiano in ogni sì ogni volta cambia
quindi la chiave rosa e quella che apre
se non sbaglio il cuore
chiamo io promosso da ma ci vuole anche
il martello ognuno anche il martello per
aprirli
ma io non so comunque con cosa nostra
martello e niente dobbiamo trovare la
chiave jazz
cos'è fatto fare non lo so mi appassiona
posata manuel ubeto
sei tu ok sono spaventato
hai trovato qualcosa non ho trovato
questa chiave grigia però non so che
cosa sia
non ho mai visto il lucchetto grigio
dove se poi vicino mi aveva visto lo
sapeva
dov'era mamma mia mi chiamo che fa
venire a questo ruolo
non è possibile dove è la chiave gialla
quando cerchiamo cerchiamo che ansia ma
lo raccomando lasciato un bel mi piace e
se questo video al 25 mila miti
accettarmi una seconda parte ha messo un
sacco di trappole
ecco è trovata una papre di la pratica
chiama gialla che cosa apre la chiave
gialla è rimangiato siano due porte
gialle proviamo ad aprire questo che
è bravo e poi dovrebbe esserci un'altra
chiave ecco chiede blu nave blu perfetto
dopo la mezz'ora sopra la prendo io no
io ho preso quello giallo arancione
scattiamo sopra
a che serve quella arancione non me lo
ricordo non la sinistra a sinistra ho
sbagliato qui qui qui che ci hai verde o
blu blu più sentiamo nella camera da
letto
la rosa giallorossa qui è questa che
cos'è cos'è chiave bianca per che cosa
no dobbiamo tenere giorni andrea de rosa
ok dove la chiave rosa giu
o no no lui è vicino come vicino aiuto
aiuto aiuto mi scappa scappa scappa
fuori fuori di quadri qual è la chiave
rosa per forza al posto di un'altra
chiave perché le sentite
ok invece quella bianca non tu avevi
preso la chiave rosa prima mi sembra
destino forse era nel tavolino
ecco l'altro reato veniva tu o che
precorre i ora torniamo sopra
che figo
oltre a dover scappare abbiamo anche il
tempo messi c'è abbiamo solo quattro
minuti qui e adesso chiave rosa vai sta
perdendo siamo in bagno che bello o no è
ora ma non ci diventi questo bagno
dai prendi la presa ok dai vini quello
che ho molta ansia sono entrato in
un'altra camera c'è la cesta accetta ok
ma prendi la prendi la ora sentiamo già
da qua sicura sì o chiudiamo andare
fuori
scopo di qua no no a vento lui è fuori
se sì se si scappiamo di qua dalla porta
d'entrata eh si io
mi stai seguendo dobbiamo andare nella
parte di sotto del bigg ha preso uno non
ci credete qui proprio qui
stati il peccato ora devo tornare di lei
prendere il marziano per andare il
martello non credo di farcela veloce che
c'entra minuti vai vai vai fratello non
mi ricordo neanche dove era aspetta io
controllo dove lui fa se sei un nostro
pallino faggiano che allora figli eccolo
fini e al piano di sopra e al di sopra
quindi scendi scendi
no
ha vinto nostro fondo
qualche altra volta dobbiamo riuscirci
dai problemi pare che arriva per primo
mentre dentro al bashment dobbiamo unire
i nostri post ci dobbiamo fare diciamo
no
ed eccomi qua tornare ai perfetti con
fiocchetto allora che volevo provare
prendo tutti per uscirne
da arrivando a
soprattutto devo prendere per primo quel
mio fan che mi ha mangiato prima
sì mi sembra di essere il basilisco di
harry potter dove siete mettiamo un po
di trappole
cerchiamo cerchiamo qua mi sa che è
passato da vita
devo subito a trovare quel giocatore
eccolo ti prendono unità omaggio a
scappare
oggi pure vitale ed
è scappato fuori mano lo prendo
perché mi hai mangiato prima stavo per
vincere il gioco perché viaggiato e
velocissimo non riesco a prenderlo
fermati oboe noi siamo delle schiappe
core che fa devo mettere più trappole
più
marchi e non so come o prendo questo
giocatore certi e bucato
manca solo vita né io metto
io mi presentavo vita non credo proprio
no io non ho visto nessuno sa dire di no
a
scappare le file velocissimo e vitale
cameron so che non posso sempre qua
vitale
ok allora io mi vedo bene tu vediamo ci
sia posto per apprendere la chiave
gialla quasi una chiave blu no ma
no per fare questo non servono a niente
lo puoi scambiare con con qualche altra
chiave
io parto fra poco a trovare la chiamata
la vediamo le cifre giallo arancione ma
vabbè ragione dalla uguale qui c'è una
chiave blu devi salire subito sopra
allora io sono ancora fermo qui ecco mi
aiutate vediamo così dai tre schemi
rilasciate un mi piace per parlarmi
dobbiamo farci io vado fuori così come
se trovo qualcuno qua fuori e apriamo
gli altri giocatori sono qua con me mi
stanno facendo compagnia sono con te no
volevo dire sono ancora lavorare molto
interessante e da allora qui abbiamo una
chiara ei
sta crollando dove sono le chiavi
aiuto per il gruppo è che chi ha la
chiave verde
c'è qualcuno qui con una chiave di
celeste che sto inseguendo
grazie
[Musica]
a youtube dove no sono al piano di sotto
io
faccio una chiave è arrivato
per lui mi ricordo di tutti non è il
piano di sotto insieme a me
qui si vive do
non c'è proprio sono profili di voi
dove devo andare dovuto vera chiave
biancamano americano dove rachele
bianchi cavour come riuscita tra non ci
voleva la chiave rota manette ce l'avevo
prima
ok io sento trapelato ma dove l'ho
lasciata io mi sto inseguendo tutti a 3
qualcuno aveva lasciato
contenuti stavo farò mi sembra aiuto
vitale dietro il divano
bellissimo i nascondo fetido un divano
quando passa qualcuno sta
ha
trattato i minuti abbiamo cinque minuti
dove caspita era la chiave rod ha
scoperto un bel passaggio segreto
quattro minuti ma dove siete non riesco
a trovarli e il martello
qualcuno ha messo la dinamite che
succede ho messo la dinamica è appreso è
aperto il cancello qui la cava grigia
per il cancello per uscire venite qua
che vi aspetta a luci ecco poi c'è il
giocatore che ha trovato la chiave
grigia
seguiamo lo
vediamo cosa cela sotto
la chiave rosa ma non mi serve adesso
greco non ti serve lei appena aperto
qualcuno acquista brand all uscita
perciò a scappare ma non solo prenderò
ci è riuscito no ancora non ci sono io
qua sto andando a mangiare non mangia
turn over uscita l'uscita era qua ma
adesso non mangiate non c'è più la
chiave con adesso devi trovare la chiave
grigia grigia o
devo aprire quel noto
in tre minuti devo trovare la chiave
capito e difficili e non dico e non ti
devo mangiare dall'altro
non ci credo della fedeltà ho preso un
altro no sono rimasta solo io o no
due minuti ce la faremo mai allora la
chiave grigio forse qui sul tavolo ma
non lo so provo ad aspettarti qui non
merito magari quando arrivi ti posso
mangiare non mi fido per niente no
49 bianca non è grigio va protetto bordo
lo so spero che vada bene rotta
altrimenti io ho perso
vediamo
partiamo da qua
aiuto mi sono nascosto testi posso
mangiare
o no
[Musica]
non ci credo ce l'ho in forza a roma
perché devi prendere la scelta l'accetta
forza no non credo
dove l'hai lasciata l'accetto
ma non lasciata sotto
no non ce la farò mai in un minuto e di
quanti aspetto giù in cantina no non ci
credo è troppo difficile far venire
troppa ansia
farina
che manca così poco
e qualità
che può
ma per poco ero lì vicino prossima
partita
ci ha seguito ve lo avevo visto quello
che
ha detto tu troppo divertente questo
store penso se volete vederne altri la
super b piace ora vi lasciamo 4 cosa lì
dentro cui dedicare per vedere i nostri
altri video cliccate su quella che
preferite buona visione ciao